noch gestern lebten hier tausende nun
steht es in flammen das umstrittene
flüchtlingscamp moria auf der
griechischen insel lesbos nach
behördenangaben brach das feuer am
frühen mittwochmorgen aus die ursachen
sind noch unklar
das war mein haus sagt dieser mann nun
ist es weg
alles was ich habe ist weg gerüchten
zufolge handelt es sich um brandstiftung
je nach quelle durch inselbewohner oder
durch die flüchtlinge selbst
rund 30 feuerwehrleute und freiwillige
helfer versuchen den brand zu löschen
der durch heftige winde angefacht wird
das flüchtlingslager moria hier
archivbilder war schon lange umstritten
da hoffnungslos überfüllt die zahl der
bewohner war viermal so groß wie die
kapazität des camps verschärfend hinzu
kommen die auswirkungen der korona
pandemie nach angaben griechischer
behörden waren zuletzt 35 bewohner
infiziert in der vergangenheit kam es
immer wieder zu teilweise gewaltsamen
protesten gegen das lager sowohl von
einheimischen als auch von den bewohnern
selbst wie befinden sich nach bild
informationen nun auf feldern und
flügeln in der umgebung des camps
teilweise bewacht von der griechischen
polizei
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren